[Musique]
bonjour à tous je m'appelle axel je suis
élève à l'école sainte-marie écoles et
surdité qui est situé tout à côté dans
laquelle j'ai fait toute ma scolarité je
suis actuellement en 5e secondaire et je
vous présente cindy et vient bonjour à
tous donc je m'appelle city m'a raté je
suis enseignante institutrice primaire à
l'école sainte-marie convient de dire
actuelle et plus précisément pour la sbm
est collée sur édité à le roman mon
travail c'est je suis institutrice 1re
2e primaire mais pour des enfants sourds
en langue des signes est collé surdité
c'est une asbl qui amène un projet
d'inclusion d'enfants sourds au sein de
classes ordinaires
vous allez me dire c'est un grand mot
pour dire non à un tas de choses plus
précisément nous sommes deux enseignants
dans la classe l'enseignant francophones
et l'enseignante en langue des signes
mois et une petite particularité c'est
que je ne suis pas du tout interprète
donc je ne vais pas crade uire ce que
mon collègue dit nous sommes en
simultané et nous travaillons vraiment
en collaboration ça c'est pour la moitié
du temps de l'horaire scolaire nous
sommes ensemble pour les cours de
mathématiques pour les cours d'éveil
par contre pour les cours de français
comme pour les cours de langue des
signes pour les cours d'anglais nous
sort retombe entre guillemets ses
enfants de leur groupe place pour les
mettre dans un plus petit groupe dans un
plus petit local où je suis seule avec
mes enfants sont mes élèves sous et je
leur enseigne le français
alors pourquoi sortons ses enfants de ce
groupe tout simplement parce que l'accès
aux français n'est pas le même pour un
enfant en entendant que pour un enfant
sont nous avons besoin d'autres
techniques d'autres méthodologies il
faut surtout pas se méprendre
nous nous atteignons évidemment les
mêmes objectifs
nous essayons en tous les cas d'attendre
les mêmes objectifs c'est à dire
savoir lire savoir écrit savoir
s'exprimer savoir calculer et le vivre
ensemble bien évidemment écoles et
sérénité et le progym premier projet en
europe de ce type et je pense axel que
dans le secondaire s'est plus ou moins
pareil parlons un peu du secondaire s'il
te plaît c'est vrai que pour les le
secondaire c'est à peu près le même
fonctionnement que le que pour le
primaire c'est relativement proche donc
bien évidemment nous changeons de cours
toutes les heures d'enseignants toutes
les heures l'enseignant sourds où on
langue des signes change également et
nous avons toujours ces binômes
d'enseignants ça pour nous c'est très
important
ensuite en fonction des cours donc nous
avons également certains certaines
d'heure en commun avec les camarades
entendants et de temps à autre pour un
renforcement du français pour les cours
d'anglais pour d'autres courent plus
optionnelle nous avons un besoin
d'adaptation spécifiques et auquel cas
nous sommes sortis du groupe classe
pendant une heure pendant deux heures
tant au cours duquel nous recevons donc
les cours comme les autres élèves de la
classe mais avec une méthodologie
spécifique pour nous et chacun chaque
partie du groupe avancent de façon
indépendante et nous revenons à la fin
du cours avec le groupe classe donc nous
fonctionnement comme nous fonctionnons
comme ça en ce sens le parfois de façon
séparée mais avec un seul objectif celui
d'avant le même programme les mêmes
contenus
à la fin de l'année mais dis-moi sine
die une petite question comment est-ce
que tu en es venu toi la langue des
signes
c'est une bonne question axel comme vous
pouvez le constater je suis donc une
personne bilingue jeu c'est à la fois
m'exprimer en français et en langue des
signes
d'ailleurs je tiens à remercier
pascaline interprète que vous entendez
maintenant ce n'est pas ma voix n'est ce
pas que vous entendez c'est bien la voix
de l'interprète
alors il faut savoir qu'à l'âge de 16
ans à la fin de mes études secondaires
je me suis posé la question de mon
avenir professionnel
alors j'étais à cette époque-là
fortement attirés par les langues
j'avais envie déjà d'apprendre l'anglais
le néerlandais l'allemand l'italien le
français comme vous le constater ici
maintenant
donc j'ai appris ces différentes langues
et puis ensuite j'ai eu envie d'en
apprendre une autre un peu plus
particulière et j'étais fortement
attirés par la langue des signes à l'âge
de 20 ans je me suis donc inscrit pour
la première fois en cours de langue des
signes
ça me ramène maintenant 17 ans en
arrière que le temps passe vite
donc j'ai une double qualification c'est
à dire je suis à la fois diplômé en
langue des signes est enseignante et
j'étais par la suite engagé donc à namur
ça fait maintenant 13 ans engagé au sein
du projet d'école du surdité
mais tu sais que je me souviens bien toi
tu étais tout petit avait 6 ans était
dans ma classe dite souvient tout à fait
tout à fait c'est vrai que ça remonte et
j'ai quand même pas mal de souvenirs
avec toi de ses années de ses deux ans
passés avec toi je j'en ai vraiment une
quantité incroyable bon j'en ai choisi
quelques-uns 2 notamment dont je que je
vais partager avec vous aujourd'hui je
ne sais pas si tu vois là le l'image
ah bah voilà leur sang en fait c'est
lili la souris petite souris toute
mignonne
on vous l'a la phrase vous la lisez de
façon simple c'est très facile mais pour
nous lorsque nous sommes plus jeunes
plus petits le français est déjà une
seconde langue et pour nous maîtriser ce
genre dénoncé est déjà relativement
complexe on a du mal à faire le lien
vendant des signes les mots français
comment est ce qu'on le formule en
langue des signes
c'est vraiment un membre entier un
apprentissage donc on a réussi à faire
et maintenant je maîtrise je comprends
très bien les non c est le second
souvenir c'est lé moment de dicter les
dictées ou alors les dictées voilà nous
sommes ensemble dans la classe
l'enseignant fait sa dictée 1
voilà le les élèves écrivent ils n'ont
pas besoin de garder le professeur en
fait c'est pas nécessaire ils sont avec
lui et entendent donc ils écrivent
sauf que nous nous avons besoin de
regarder pour avoir la langue des signes
de regarder l'enseignant et d'écrire en
même temps donc on utilise le lpc dans
ce cas là le lpc signifie langage parlé
complété et c'est une aide un outil à la
reconnaissance phonologique des mots et
c'est vrai que c'est une aide
intéressante pour les enfants sourds
c'est vrai que pour nous c'est une grand
est d'une grande aide parce que ça nous
permet de distinguer en fait les sosies
la bio les mots qui se ressemblent que
l'on lit sur les lèvres et ça aide
beaucoup mais ça ça prend beaucoup plus
de temps
ça prend beaucoup plus de temps nous
sommes obligés de relever la tête tout
temps pour voir les enseignants pour
réécrire ne pourrait être sûr qu'on a
bien compris le mot qu'on a décodé donc
ça prend du temps et c'est on avait
vraiment un rythme très très très très
ralentie par rapport au reste de la
classe et je me souviens notamment d'une
fois où au cours d'une dictée les élèves
ont eu fini leur travail
il était le temps de la récréation donc
ils sont partis dans la cour
sauf que nous avec ce retard accumulé eh
bien nous on n'a pas pu profiter de la
récréation tout de suite et lorsque nous
avons enfin eu fini
dictée et bien en fait on s'est rendu
compte que la récréation était en phase
ii en phase terminale en fait en train
de s'achever du thé exagérer quand même
pas un peu hâte en regard d'un petit peu
maintenant est ce que vous avez vraiment
l'air malheureux et la regarde ce beau
sourire bon là c'est moi
mais c'est vrai tu as raison c'est vrai
que tout début du projet on essayait de
suivre l'enseignant francophone
maintenant les choses ont beaucoup
évolué et la méthode qu'on utilise la
pédagogie qu'on utilise a beaucoup
changé donc à beaucoup d'adaptations
maintenant qu'on a su mettre en place et
c'est notamment pour ça qu'on sort les
enfants sourds du grand groupe pour les
cours de français parce que justement on
a mis en place une méthode
particulièrement bien adapté de sorte
que vous puissiez garder ou quand même
votre temps de récréation
c'est vrai que c'est la ville saison des
projets qui évolue qui évolue forcément
pour nous au niveau du secondaire
on en est pas encore avec autant de
modifications autant d'évolutions c'est
vrai que le projet a commencé avec les
années du primaire
donc qui maintenant sont sont bien en
place là les années du secondaire ont
commencé il y a relativement peu tout de
même donc ce n'est pas encore aussi
abouti on
on avance tous ensemble on reprend
quelques idées qu'on fait confions
modifie moi ça fait cinq ans que je suis
maintenant niveau du secondaire et je me
rends compte que ça a déjà beaucoup
évolué alors c'est vrai que l'école et
surdité c'est vraiment un modèle
incroyable pour nous on a vraiment une
grande chose c'est vraiment une grande
chance c'est vraiment incroyable cette
chance que j'ai c'est vraiment un
enrichissement ce bilinguisme français
et langue des signes et les élèves
entendant souvent me disent mais dites
donc c'est vraiment beau la langue des
signes comme ça c'est on à imad 10 à
plusieurs reprises de voilà que
l'enseignant tendant parfois est moins
agréable et écoutés et que la langue des
signes c'est vraiment plus intéressant
ça apporte une ouverture et ça
interpelle beaucoup parfois on me
demande également mais comment tu dis ça
en langue des signes tels mots comment
tu le comment on fait et c'est vraiment
intéressant pour nous de pouvoir faire
des ponts entre les deux mondes ray de
communauté et d'avoir cette ces échanges
parfois on a aussi beaucoup de voix là
de petits moments des changes plus
informel on s'est vraiment c'est
vraiment un moment intéressant mais toi
dis moi tu es tu es un enseignant
bilingue mais travaillant comme ça du
lundi au vendredi toute la semaine tu
dois être crevé la fin de la semaine non
ben complètement épuisé non alors c'est
vrai qu'il ya beaucoup de travail
être enseignant en soi c'est déjà un
métier difficile donc maintenant être
enseignant bilingue
effectivement c'est quand même encore
une double difficulté à assumer
alors comme je vous le disais je ne suis
pas interprète c'est à dire que je mets
moi-même en oeuvre montcourt j'adapte le
le contenu du cours en fonction du
programme
alors il faut quand même savoir que par
chance on a beaucoup de soutien de la
part des cols et surdité
en effet on a notamment des formations
spécifiques notamment une fois par mois
le mercredi après midi le centre de
l'université de namur est organisé un
groupe
travail au sein duquel on a l'occasion
d'apporter nos question d'avoir des
échanges particulièrement intéressant et
particulièrement enrichissant pour notre
pédagogie et nous avons également des
réunions hebdomadaires entre enseignants
bilingues et tout ça nous est apportée
par eco les surdités donc un grand
soutien de leur part heureusement n'est
pas seul à devoir réaliser toutes ces
atteintes adaptation maintenant je me
pose une petite question de concernant
tu es encore jeune mais est ce que tu
sais déjà ce que tu as envie de faire
plus tard
alors c'est vrai que je pense que les
personnes sourdes ici présentes savent
quelle quelle est mon rêve mon rêve
serait de rendre accessibles afin de
faire apparaître langue des signes à la
télévision de façon à ce qu'on puisse
avoir
voilà deux les informations une avec une
accessibilité parfaite en fait ça c'est
vraiment mon objectif est de façon
générale écoles et surdité
avec ce bilinguisme en construction peut
être peut permettre d'atteindre cet
objectif de façon plus facile maintenant
je vous avais peut-être une information
que je suis déjà j'ai déjà fait un peu
de télévision
c'est vrai waouh ça remonte à deux ans
le 2 mars 2016 donc il ya deux ans sur
l'a2 attend justement regarde un peu
et maintenant on passe à la météo tout
d'abord avec notre image satellite vous
le voyez les prochains jours seront
propices à des giboulées fréquente de
neige parfois même à basse altitude
on va faire le point tout de suite sur
la situation de cette nuit avec de
l'instabilité toujours cette nuit du
vent qui se renforcent des pluies et de
la neige mêlées sur l'ensemble du
territoire
nagy seul même qui pourrait tenir sur
les hauteurs pour
[Musique]
dit-on coin et oui alors c'est moi cette
expérience m'a vraiment voilà c'est
vraiment une grande émotion pour moi
j'imagine une grande émotion pour moi
c'était vraiment un pas immense en fait
qui a été accompli ici
alors ce jour de mars voilà tout de
suite après j'ai eu beaucoup de
personnes qui me contactent et qui m'ont
demandé mais dites donc tu veux tu va
refaire sa fin et oui j'aimerais bien
j'aimerais bien j'aimerais bien ayant
beaucoup de personnes m'ont dit j'espère
que tu auras vraiment la chance de
recommencer d'atteindre celle temps de
réaliser ton rêve
bon alors maintenant est ce que je le
pourrai vraiment ça je ne sais pas mais
j'espère vraiment j'espère pouvoir
renouveler cette expérience un jour un
jour prochainement
j'espère également pour toi on touche du
bois mais il n'y a pas de bois
et toi cindy ton rêve certainement pas
la météo ça très clairement je peux déjà
te le dire alors voilà j'ai déjà
l'enseignement est déjà un travail que
j'adore je suis enseignant bilingue
c'est un métier que j'adore je suis
également comédienne
je suis également musicienne tu tombes
sont toutes les trois des activités
vraiment que j'adore et j'ai encore des
choses que je dois réaliser mais pour la
plupart j'ai l'impression que j'ai déjà
réalisé un des très grands rêves que
j'avais quand je te vois maintenant ici
comme tu es moi qui t'ai connu tout
petit qui était vu grandir
maintenant je vois que tu es capable de
lire d'écrire de calculer toutes ces
choses que tu es capable de faire
peut-être d'avoir des relations plus
amicales plus affective enfin bref tu
vois ce que je veux dire et je te vois
comme ça maintenant grand bain je me dis
que quelque part je suis fait une des
petites pierres qui ont permis qui t'ont
permis de devenir ce que tu es
maintenant c'est vrai que cette petite
pierre mme quand même amené voilà une
certaine aisance maintenant merci
beaucoup et cindy
en langue des signes oui vous pouvez
applaudir comme ça c'est ce qu'on dit en
langue des signes pour loaded vu leurs
délais voilà vite
est ce que vous savez vous ce qu'on dit
des personnes sourdes ont dit en fait
qu'on est lorsqu on se rencontre on est
très très très bavard on devient très
très bavard et on reste très longtemps
sur place a discuté avec cette image de
pied de pieds rivés au sol c'est
vraiment une expression propre chez nous
bon allez il faut arrêter il faut qu'on
y aille a donné l'avancé on voulait
laisser la place on est à raison a dit
au revoir merci beaucoup
bret s'est bien passé le censeur hier
donc la maman super
[Musique]